[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con se cumple el
décimo aniversario del inicio de la
revolución egipcia cuando miles de
ciudadanos protestaron hasta sacar del
poder al ex presidente hosni mubarak
mediante elecciones democráticas fue
elegido mohamed morsi pero su mandato
finalizó en 2013 con un golpe de estado
que llevó al poder al gobierno militar
de abdel fattah al sitio para analizar
este tema conversamos con pedro rivas él
es profesor de relaciones
internacionales y dice decano de la
universidad loyola en andalucía profesor
rivas buenos días gracias por
acompañarnos hosni mubarak llevaba 30
años en el poder cuando iniciaron las
protestas recordemos cuál era el
sentimiento general de la ciudadanía
cuando iniciaron estas movilizaciones en
pues cuando iniciaron estas
movilizaciones estaban recordando el
éxito de una cosa semejante que había
ocurrido en túnez en túnez un muchacho
se había quemado ante una bofetada que
le había dado una policía y era un signo
precisamente del oprobio cometido contra
la población civil y algo parecido
estaba ocurriendo en efecto con una
represión continuada de la población
seis meses antes de este levantamiento
un muchacho educado con formación
occidental incluso rico había señor
torturado y muerto por la policía y las
gentes especialmente los jóvenes decenas
de miles de personas habían ocupado la
plaza tahrir el maidán la explanada
central el campo de marte del cairo
pidiendo precisamente la deposición de
mubarak aquellos 18 días de movilización
en principio por gente es casi se
polariza das llevaron a esa deposición
convocada en nombre de amnistía que
acabaron uso cuando los istas los
hermanos musulmanes en cierta medida
gracias y digo gracias a la eficacia que
tuvo al yazira
la emisión qatarí que durante 18 días de
forma ininterrumpida estuvo emitiendo
esta toma de la plaza tahrir y daba la
sensación de que los hermanos musulmanes
eran quienes estaban dirigiendo aquello
cuando en realidad estaban fagocitando
esa revolución popular profesor derrocar
a mubarak era el objetivo principal
desde el inicio del movimiento a que más
aspiraba al pueblo egipcio cuando se
logró la salida de mubarak del poder
parte del pueblo egipcio aspiraba a un
modelo democrático un modelo democrático
occidental eso era complicado por dos
motivos porque parte de la población
egipcia la más piadosa en cierta medida
aún confiaba en un modelo no islamista
no de islam degradado pero que tampoco
tuviera el nivel de secularización de
una democracia usual y el grueso de los
militares también eran contrarios
recuerde usted que desde el año 1954
cuando nasser acaba debilitando con gran
violencia a los hermanos musulmanes
durante 50 años ellos están quietos y
después de nacer llegas a edad y después
llega a mubarak que ocurrió que en
realidad aquella revolución que
intentaba implantar un régimen político
distinto
los hermanos musulmanes acabaron ganando
las elecciones y tras un año en el poder
precisamente al sisi dio un golpe de
estado
volviendo a llevar una tradición
profundamente militarizada que era la de
egipto con un problema añadido a la de
los tiempos de mubarak unos niveles de
represión y de muertes aún mayores que
los que habían tenido haciendo casi
bueno al viejo dictador que había gozado
del respaldo occidental
profesor mohamed morsi de los hermanos
musulmanes duró apenas un año en el
poder tras haber sido pues el primer
presidente electo democráticamente
porque falló este experimento
democrático
cuando los hermanos musulmanes toman el
poder tienen el respaldo de qatar e
incluso tienen 3000 millones de dólares
de esta monarquía del golfo precisamente
para mantenerse en el poder eso
atemoriza a arabia saudí y atemoriza
también a otras monarquías que están en
la margen izquierda del mar rojo
arabia saudi principalmente junto con
los emiratos árabes le da a los
militares al sisi cuatro veces más doce
mil millones de dólares para que en caso
de que el golpe de estado prospere se
puedan mantener eficazmente en el poder
y eso es lo que ocurrió al margen del
golpe de estado de los militares un
equilibrio de fuerzas que estaban
planteando lo siguiente egipto no tiene
la fuerza que tuvo en su día ha
engordado ha envejecido está miope pero
no se puede dejar llevar a caer por una
fuerza revolucionaria como es ese islam
político de los hermanos musulmanes
habrá que retornar a un orden
autoritario que mantenga estable en la
región para que entre otras cosas el
conflicto palestino-israelí no se
degrade y para que el yihadismo
especialmente el del sinaí no se
fortalezca esos son dos grandes vectores
que en cierta medida
pitaron el retorno de los militares y
que hicieron que los occidentales europa
incluida con frecuencia mirarán para
otro lado profesor muy brevemente cuando
del fatal si se llegó a la presidencia
llegó a la presidencia en 2014 hay más
represión en este momento hay más
violencia
hay más violencia hay más gente en las
cárceles hay más juventud emigrando y
hay aún más pobreza tengan en cuenta que
de los 80 millones de egipcios el 50 por
ciento tienen menos de 25 años tienen
pocas oportunidades e incluso algunos
oyen en sus casas que estaban mejor con
lugar así del pse cuento entonces de
cuál es la situación en este momento en
el país profesor muchas gracias a
ustedes gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con nosotros en france 24
[Música]